White House senior advisor jared kushner
the president's son-in-law is in Iraq
this morning officials in the White
House and Iraq confirmed the visit to
CBS News Kushner landed in Iraq minutes
ago as part of an unannounced trip with
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff Kushner was a key figure in the
Trump campaign and his role in the
administration is expanding he was just
named head of a task force to modernize
government Krishna also reportedly
helped organize this week's scheduled
meeting between mr. Trump and Chinese
President Xi Jinping they're expected to
discuss North Korea's growing nuclear
threat President Trump told the
Financial Times if China is not going to
solve North Korea we will major Garrett
is at the White House major good morning
good morning lots to talk about first
the president's meeting with Xi Jinping
later this weekend at mar-a-lago is
North Korea at the top of the agenda
it's very difficult for this president
to take on the Chinese government
without first leading with economics he
spent a lot of his campaign talking
about China's a currency manipulator
someone who has abused the United States
through trade deal so that has to be a
focus but if you're gonna engage China
on economic matters right behind it as
North Korea and that's where the
pressure point is because if this
president if this administration wants
to move China to be more cooperative
with it dealing with North Korea it
might have to back off some of the
aggressiveness it would like to take on
economic matters and the two biggest
issues for this administration and China
with North Korea is does this
administration consider sanctions
against Chinese company that do business
in North Korea or discourage the Chinese
from using and paying North Korea for
North Korean labor both things might
change the relationship between China
North Korea and give them and the United
States more influence over North Korea's
pursuit of nuclear weapons all of that
will be on the table at mar-a-lago we
have just heard reports of jared kushner
being in Iraq what is his role in barn
policy and is he shaping it or simply
executing it he is shaping it in this
sense he's there to listen for the
President and to make sure that all
those who are collecting information
that will be funneled up to the
president be they military or diplomatic
also understand that Jared cushion
is there to be the trusted adviser to
the President to also add whatever he
interprets the military or diplomatic
advice coming to the president is about
or where it should lead and with the
Middle East there are a lot of important
meetings to this week Egypt Jordan there
been conversations with the Saudis last
week the administration said the Syrian
government is up for the people of Syria
to decide a lot of thick movements going
on in the Middle East jared kushner is
trying to shape all of that for the
president to create some new realities
after the Obama administration it
reminds me of James Baker saying to us
the most important thing someone who is
engaged in foreign policy can do is have
the confidence of the President thank
you mean that's what Jared Kushner has